if the shoe fits wear it I take apart
the new Cinderella on this week's
episode of angry nerd press your
comments Rodney funderburke rights can
you make a video about whether books or
movies are better for franchises like
Harry Potter Lord of the Rings and
Twilight Rodney books and movies are two
totally different mediums and each are
good in their own ways except for
Twilight Twilight books and movies are
each bad in their own ways a live-action
version of Disney Cinderella is coming
out and it's giving me a powerful sense
of deja vu I mean there have been 13
movie adaptation to this story it just
since 2000 including into the woods just
a couple of months ago I don't see what
sets this new Kenneth Branagh adaptation
apart except more plot machinations with
the wicked stepmother yawn why is this
returning yet another animated classic
into live action what's because
Maleficent earned over 750 million i
just say Teresa yeah I figure that was a
reason why but i guess this new
Cinderella doesn't really have to
reinvent the wheel because the four
hundred year old story line is so
durable and so universally appealing I
mean people just naturally respond to
the downtrodden protagonists who special
qualities are finally recognized I can
guarantee you they'll still be staging
Cinderella and outpost on Rigel seven of
the Year 2395 a story with that sort of
timeless appeal is potent stuff I mean
seriously has anybody in our lifetime
come up with the tale that we can
confidently predict will still be in
circulation for centuries from now I
would save George Lucas I mean the man
has a lot to answer for but in the pre
prequel era he really tapped into
something private I remember when rain
of fire when the adult stage star wars
for the kids ah
you're fun that was the best scene in
that post apocalyptic dud who else's
work will endure Stanley maybe future
generations will still wish that they
could be like the wallflower who gains
extraordinary superpowers and they'll
probably think that 20th century people
were also gullible and superstitious
that we really believe that radioactive
arachnids would actually have that
effect I knew that wasn't how science
works people from the distant future
revive my cryo frozen head I will
explain our era to you who else stands
the test of time well Disney yeah John
Lasseter it's likely dr. suks match
Miyamoto of course JK Rowling know
they'll find the educational system
elitist brutalizing Michael Bay are you
kidding this stuff seems archaic now so
Dizzy's doing a live action Cinderella
this year a live-action jungle book and
beauty and the beast coming next year I
mean what's next a live-action Pirates
of the Caribbean what what no no you're
mistaken see it's very sophisticated
animatronics just like the ride no no no
cuz i read it in variety that's they're
not real people I hate it when you go
well and then you tell me I'm wrong when
I know that I'm right there animatronic
robots no no well we'll agree to
disagree ha I guess I'm assuming that
the future peoples of the 24th century
won't have super short attention spans
maybe they're touchstones will be like
charlie bit my finger or the cat who
likes to jump into boxes what do you
think is the most durable story of our
time let me know in the comments
subscribe to the wire channel and click
on my videos over there with the the
tiny animatronic versions of me like no
no they're animatronic I mean see look
how stiff and jerky their movements are
what a thing to say to me you know i
think you are animatronic yeah i thought
so real human being couldn't be that
heartless